would be a good reason to choose to run Syrex antibody testing. So it would be a good reason
for I'm assuming you're saying a cancer patient, but let's just use for anybody.
So because it's going to apply to a person with cancer as well. So you'd run antibody testing
if you are suspected that you have either. So if you're ready, auto antibody. So auto means self.
So if you're ready to self antibodies, you're ready to antibodies to your own tissue
to see if you have an autoimmune disease. So the reason why you'd run that test is if you have
signs or symptoms that are suggestive of an autoimmune disease. So what would those be? Well,
they can be as varied as the variable different autoimmune diseases. So let's say I have let's
let's use an example. I have some early dementia and I'm forgetting things and
or I'm having motor or neuron issues. We need like a dropping things or I'm starting to get a
tremor or something like that. And you're suspecting auto antibodies or self antibodies
to neural tissue to brain tissue. That would be a perfect valid reason to run antibody testing.
Let's say I have thyroid issues. I'm tired all the time, but my CBC and looks good. I don't have
anemia and I'm having loss of hair and I'm losing the lateral third of my eyebrows and I read that
that is possible thyroid issues. But the thyroid test that my doctor did wasn't sufficient to
see antibodies. That would be a reason to run antibody testing. If you have, you know, weird
rashes, weird, you know, any weird symptoms that maybe even watching some videos on my autoimmune
course and you're starting to realize, boy, this could be me. That would be a reason to run
antibody testing. CyRx also runs food antibody testing. So that's not self antibodies. So understand
the difference of self antibodies is antibodies to your own tissue. You have antibodies to your
brain tissue. You have antibodies to your to your thyroid gland. You have antibodies to your
pancreas. You have it so you have an autoimmune disease. Meaning you have antibodies to self tissue.
But also if you have it got issues or have it digestive problems, you know, it's I have a lot of
inflammation. I can't pinpoint what that is. It could be diet related. So if you have antibodies
to foods that you're eating or you should say if you're eating foods to that which you have antibodies
against every time you eat those foods, you're causing this inflammatory reaction and you're gut
and your brain. And that's not good. So that would be an indication to run food antibody tests.
CyRx also has pathogen related antibodies. So if you think that you had a past pathogen or a
present pathogen, you could run that. When I have multiple other profiles that you could run
depending on the symptoms that you have. So if you want to get to the bottom of inflammation and
gut problems and maybe other inflammatory disorders, you could run food antibody testing,
pathogen antibody testing. If you want to discover whether you're not, you have an autoimmune
disease. You have antibodies to your own tissue. Then you can run self antibodies. Typically,
I run the CyRx array 5 and the CyRx array 7x to find out that. So those would be signs and
symptoms would give you indication to run those.